hello everyone exams don't always go
well and when they don't it is very
natural to feel down about it
this is the exam season across many
institutes including here at IIT
kharagpur so I thought this will be a
good time to share some tips with you
which will help you to bounce back from
a bad exam now please don't get me wrong
in this video I'm not going to prescribe
any kind of Magic Bullet rather what I'm
going to suggest is very much Common
Sense knowledge which you as intelligent
students already are aware of in your
heart of hearts but sometimes you all
need a nudge in the right direction to
help us realize what we already know
what is really required in this case is
a proper assessment of one situation
and
an honest effort in the right direction
so what do we really mean by a bad exam
because it means different things for
different kinds of students for the top
performing student for example a bad
exam would mean something which would
maybe remove them from the top of the
class
for the mid-level student it means
something different probably something
which should push them closer to the
lower half of the class and for the
other kinds of students a bad exam will
probably mean something which puts a
question mark on whether they'll be even
able to pass the subject
so we have to discuss this thing from
this different points of view so first
of all for the top performing students
uh I will take the help of uh some of a
tip which I received from the Department
rank one of my own batch here in the
mechanical engineering department
at IIT kharabp this is from way back in
2006 or seven I think uh he told me that
when an exam goes back because it used
to happen for him also very rarely but
it used to happen
what he did was to just change the
mindset okay so what he's told me was it
is ridiculously simple actually
he said that when an exam goes bad
just think that you have to minimize the
damage it is as simple as that minimize
the damage
so I will extend a little bit on that
and say that when an exam goes bad yes
you have to minimize the damage but you
also have to realize that realistically
speaking you're not going to pull off a
miracle in the rest of the semester
probably your mid semester has gone bad
uh so in the rest of the semester what
more can you do to probably you are no
more getting the highest possible grade
so just try to minimize the damage as my
friend said okay and think realistically
about it that's it you're all
intelligent very intelligent students at
the top of the class you know what you
have to do just do it that's it that's
it for the top following students I
don't think you need me more to expand
on it next for the middle students well
ah
in a in a place like IIT I think this is
the broadest category of students the
mid-level students who with some amount
of effort can actually perform very well
but sometimes a slip occurs here and
there so when an exam goes bad for you
guys what I will suggest is first do a
little bit of introspection like a
hardcore introspection why the exam went
bad
if it is purely because of your own
effort or your lack of effort actually
well you know what to do you don't need
me to tell
but sometimes what happens is that uh
the the nature of the exam is such the
nature of the course the subject is such
that uh despite your best efforts it may
not be possible to perform well in the
examination
if you do not have a very very good a
high level of on the spot problem
solving ability inside the pressure
cooker situation of an examination
this is something which many people do
not realize okay there are many subjects
many problem-based subjects like this in
every department for example in computer
science I think one of my friends told
me that they have this subject called
discrete maths uh where you really have
to perform on the spot in the
examination despite your best uh efforts
best despite your best preparation will
not be enough uh similarly in mechanical
engineering we have something at the
second year level called Dynamics at
least here at IIT kharagpur it is one of
the toughest subjects in our department
uh you may prepare it really well for it
but ultimately on the day of the
examination sitting there you have to
perform okay there is no other way there
is no two ways about it my own subject
mechanics of solids
well it's not the easiest of subjects
but I think uh it is it does not really
fall into that category of subject if if
you have prepared uh well uh there is no
way you're going to perform that badly
okay uh well what do you do
in this case well I would suggest that
you take inspiration for this kind of a
situation from your je days
so the reason why I'm saying this is
that see Jade level problems there the
content is very much easy it's basically
plus two physics chemistry maths so
that's not very difficult maybe
chemistry is a little bit difficult but
I mean overall the content is not
difficult but the problems are so very
hard so because of a certain level of
Ingenuity which you require to solve
these problems and that is something
which to a certain extent it is my
personal belief is God given but it can
be honed and you all have own disability
through a lot of practice so during your
JDS you you through your coaching
through your own efforts you did such a
lot of practice that even if you did not
have this god-given ability for problem
solving you did manage to do well you
did manage to crack the exam
so now just think what what what what is
missing so what is missing is that in
all likelihood for these cancer exams
you are not solving enough problems and
when I say that I mean you're not
solving enough challenging problems you
have to give yourself the time to go
through those things kind of things uh
because see your mind has your brain's
ability has not magically changed uh
just in the course of
two or three years of
so two or three years ago you did your
your J and within this span of two years
your mind has not undergone a massive
change in your problem solving ability
so if it did not happen then without
practice it is certainly not going to
happen now without practice
so you really have to understand this
thing so you have to give yourself the
time to solve challenging problems for
practice okay so without this net
practice you'll not be able to perform
in the actual uh actual field in the
actual exam
but there is a flip side to it also
suppose you realize this suppose you
take my advice and you go for a a lot of
investment of time
on one subject will that be
strategically wise think about it
because
already a large part of the semester is
over probably half the semester is over
in most of the cases as you're watching
this video and in the rest of the
already short time that you have in the
semester how much are you going to
improve your problem solving equipment
in that subject
so
think a little bit uh in a business like
fashion
how much of Return of investment are you
going to get by putting in so much
effort in just one subject will it
perhaps not be at the detriment of other
subjects where with a relatively less
amount of effort you'll be able to
really perform well because what you
really need is the overall good
performance in a semester so think about
it also okay because at the end of the
day you have to realize for these kinds
of subjects you really have to put in
that amount of time but when you do that
there are only 24 hours a day you have
to do a lot of other things also uh
the other subject should not suffer this
is this is my uh my
suggestion to you
next and finally for the students for
whom a bad exam really means a question
mark over whether they'll be even able
to pass the subject now for these kinds
of students compared to the previous two
kinds of students I think there is the
greatest scope of improvement
the reason is very simple actually you
guys are making such a lot of obvious
mistakes and the kind of mistakes which
are so very easy to fix that just with a
little bit of tweaking with a little bit
of adjustment in your working style in
your study habits you can bring about a
sea change in your results
so uh please take this seriously okay so
the most obvious kind of mistake which
which I have seen most guys like this do
and this is this is an experience I'm
pulling from my own student days when I
have seen many of my bachelors go down
this route I have seen many students
also now that have become a faculty go
down this route is that they just don't
attend classes okay so hold on before
you cringe uh this is not me as a
professor as a faculty member giving out
the usual rent okay so just hear me out
so when I say that
you really need to add in classes I
really mean that you need to add in
classes not just physically out of the
fear of completing your attendance
requirement the mandatory attendance
requirement which which some professors
have some some institutes have rather I
mean being actually mentally properly
present in the class and engage with
what the professor is trying to teach
see for most courses there are only
three or four hours of lectures right
so
see there are 168 hours per week
seven days 24 hours
out of that can you not spare three or
four hours for a subject in which there
is actually a question mark of whether
you are going to pass or fail think
about it
on top of that you read if you really
want to push your improvement a little
bit further I would say the best way and
this is especially required for
problem-based courses is that in
addition to those three four hours you
also invest
not more than two three hours for for
information based courses which are not
at all problem based uh I think just
attending the lectures enough is enough
you don't even have to go for any kind
of self-study in your room but for
problem-based courses yes beyond the
lectures you need to keep up and uh
train your mind a little bit by going
for some kind of problem solving uh not
more than two hours so maybe two hours
three hours for harder courses so out of
those 168 hours that are present in a
week
can you not spare it like six seven
hours in total out of which four hours
are therefore actually attending the
lectures and here is the Zinger actually
see many of you are thinking that oh I
don't have the time I have lots of other
things lots of extracurricular
activities co-curricular activities I
have to go for uh programming in AIML
because that is what I want to go uh I
do not have the time to study these
things I'd not have even six or seven
hours
but see if you if you just invest these
six seven hours now every week
later on you will not be so just before
the examination the amount of time that
you have to waste trying to find out the
notes from all the regular students
trying to find out what the syllabus is
what the teacher has taught what are the
important things for which this teacher
has given implicit hints uh for you to
do well in the examination and mind you
in the semester system this always
happens so people who are regularly
attending classes they get some implicit
hints okay the teacher of course is not
going to give away the questions but
some implicit hints of what is actually
important really important and on which
he is interested in testing the students
this will be evident to all the
regularly attending students so when you
do this
you almost give yourself this kind of an
of a direct Advantage so why not uh why
not exploit this okay
so my suggestion is that
just just give it a chance okay inverse
six seven hours out of which only four
hours are there for uh already there for
your lectures and see if it uh if it
doesn't bring about a marked improvement
in your results
okay so I really hope you will take my
advice uh
and just and one last thing which I
always want always point out to my
students here at IIT kharagpur also is
that see if you're not attending classes
what are you basically doing
you may think you may think that okay I
am taking advantage of the various kinds
of opportunities here uh in the campus
uh the various extracurricular
activities fine you're doing that but in
the process
uh
see your parents are investing so much
money for your education okay and just
hear me out
uh when you have paid your semester fees
and you are not attending classes what
you're basically doing is helping in
improving the teacher student ratio for
the benefit of the students who are
actually regularly attending the classes
so it is I know it's it's kind of
harsh for me to point it out like this
but you are in fact basically paying for
their better education
okay so I leave this at leave it this
think about it and see if you really
want to improve because that is what is
really required
some students just don't want to improve
well in that case none of this advice
applies but if you really want to
improve if you are really feeling
honestly down about a bad exam maybe
think seriously about implementing this
pieces of advice so all the very best to
all of you uh to all the kinds of
students and I hope that this little
video will help you really genuinely to
improve by the time the end semester
comes along so all the very best to all
of you thank you